hi four three two one
is the mark Joey wants to be today Timmy
directs Janice is the most likely along
with Pat fertile Eddie to be Joey here
today timmi e pterence 90 seconds exist
the future is the property of the
iron-willed and there is only one man
who has an iron will and it is he go
away just 30 seconds left Eric Denmark
doing very 5 4 3 2 1 so absolutely i was
trying to rake the record i'm always
trying to push myself I'm happy I tied
it I'm happy I won it would been great
to eat 70 but there's always next year
and the next year I'm gonna be going
with my seventh straight win and 70 it
sounds like a good number of still as we
say a furry humane change that grace and
elegance and loveliness
but i have seen history made sonya
thomas now push count it down with me
from 10 9 8 7 6 5 4 3 2 1 put down your
hot dogs I know that I can I can do it
well 45 in the 50 hot dogs buns but not
of 10 minutes but it's more mental
control and mentoring and I say I'm
gonna eat in today's i said to my goal
and I don't want to disappoint myself
and I pushed myself and I really
fighting with me and he worked